[Music]
a silver-haired princess a tween made a
wife to a cousin and a dreamboat who can
really handle a lance all of westeros
came from the pen of george r.r martin
then television gave it a glossy
makeover
house of the dragon's king viserys
played by paddy considine is a
sympathetic but somewhat feckless man
who might not be as well suited to rule
as was his grandfather king j harris he
looks weary but genuinely healthy except
for those pesky lacerations he sustains
from setting the iron throne the ones
that ominously won't heal this the
series is in middle age and of average
height and build he's got long silvery
hair and the scruffy beard of a king who
isn't trying too hard to impress anybody
he wears a crown of gold and silver
embossed with the targaryen crest
and he gets a bit more dressed up for
tournaments which he enjoys planning
though not as much as he loves fiddling
with his enormous model of valyria and
it was never my brother's strongest
trait
what
being king
one of the shows that serious a sort of
a sad sack of borderline beta male
firing bloods is like the santa claus of
king's landing a returned jolly party
king
he sported a bushy silvery gold mustache
started out pleasantly plump and got
softer and plumper throughout his reign
book viserys really likes tornies feasts
bulls and any other occasion to
celebrate and the people really liked
him in return because he kept the wine
flowing and the entertainment going
matt smith's prince damon targaryen is
one of the breakout stars of house of
the dragon smith absolutely nails
damon's demeanor and he's a close enough
physical representation of what martin
had in mind for the rogue prince who is
one of martin's favorite characters
though firing blood burns through his
narrative much more quickly than
martin's a song of ice and fire the
author pauses to make sure we know what
damon looks and acts like we meet him as
a hot-tempered and quarrelsome man of
20. later descriptions pepper in terms
like impetuous charming dashing daring
a renowned warrior dangerous and all
that his brother was not you're weak
viserys
and that council of leeches knows it
they all prey on you for their own ends
the written damon is tall and trim like
smith and has flowing silver hair bold
armor and a gold cloak just as the
costume and makeup departments have
styled him bug damien is however
portrayed as broader shouldered and more
intimidating and while smith is
certainly handsome in his own
distinctive way reader's impression of
prince damon's face is that he's so
universally perceived as good looking
it's easy to excuse what martin has
called in interviews notorious bad boy
behavior while some of house of the
dragons characters will be replaced by
new actors as they age up damon will be
played by matt smith throughout that's
in keeping with the books as well in
which damon is a man whose personality
and appearance barely change at all
throughout the years
in both the book and the show young
princess rhaenyra is proclaiming the
realms delight in fire and blood we
first hear about her at the age of six
when she is described as precocious
bright beautiful and bold she starts
serving as her father's cup bearer
around the age of eight and she enjoys a
close perhaps too close relationship
with her uncle damon who assures her
that she's the fairest maid in all the
seven kingdoms she wears her silver gold
hair and braids and wears a lot of
jewelry book ray nearer was shapely
before motherhood but never lost the
weight she'd put on during pregnancy
martin calls her stout and thick of
waist and says her beauty faded by age
20. after a brief prologue house of the
dragon opens with a shot of teenage
raniera riding her dragon cyrax through
the skies above king's landing
everyone says targaryens are closer to
gods than to men
but they say that because of our dragons
the princess of dragonstone is an
accomplished dragon rider in the books
as well young rhaenyra is played by
millie alcock often wears pastels and
uncomplicated hairstyles now after a
time jump she's played by emma darcy who
was decked out in reds and blacks and
layers of jewels
darcy looked physically and mentally
sharp as adult
the particulars about allison's high
towers physicality haven't been altered
much from the source material in both
the daughter of the hand of the king
otto hightower is depicted as
traditionally feminine and exceedingly
attractive so much so that the king
turned us back on a much more
politically advantageous marriage to wed
her instead i thought i might come and
look in on you grace
i brought a book martin doesn't get into
too much detail about her appearance
again he or his fictional narrator
focuses instead on her body type fire
and blood tells us that she was clever
and lovely as fertile as she was pretty
and that she remained slender and
graceful even after birthing many
children what is dramatically different
about allison's however is the age in
her relationship with rhaenyra in the
book allison comes to court with her
father when she's already 15. at this
time rhaenyra is only a small child the
show was aged her down as to ramp up the
drama and make her the princess's best
friend before she becomes her mortal
enemy
fire and blood doesn't really tell us
what sir otto hightower looks like it's
said that some of the high towers had
silvery gold hair similar to valyrian
families like the targaryens and
valerians but they're one of the old
money houses of westeros's seven
kingdoms where their family seat in old
town gives them access to the citadel's
library as one might expect from this
littlefinger-like ladder climber the
inner workings of his mind are of more
consequence to martin than is the face
that hides a multitude of schemes and
plots i've never been one for signs of
importance your grace but if the gods
did wish to show their favor otto is
described as able proud and haughty
reecey vernes perfectly executes otto's
subtle treachery his even temperament
comes off favorably against his rival
prince damon targaryen's impulsivity his
careful word choice is evidence of its
intelligence and self-interest we can't
know for sure if daemon actually says or
does the things that the hand of the
king accuses him of but when he tells
the series that he does not envy him for
having to marry again out of duty you
are the king
[Music]
but i do not envy you it's a sly way of
proposing instead that the king marry
his daughter for love
the valarians are one of only three
families who have escaped the doom of
valyria and they claim their roots go
even further back than the mighty
targaryens while people of valyrian
descent have been described throughout
martin's books as having silvery hair
purple eyes and pale skin not all of
them do and martin doesn't bother to
tell us much about what cordless looks
like martin describes callus as as
brilliant as he was restless and as
adventurous as he was ambitious corliss
who goes on to become the greatest
seafarer ever is responsible for turning
his house from a minor one aligned with
the targaryens into a major one that
competes for a share of the throne when
i ascended the driftwood throne
i knew what i wanted
so i went out and seized it the
valyrians have long served the
targaryens with their ships and
kingsguards but cordless enterprising
more than doubled his family's fortune
and his marriage to reynes and the birth
of dragon-riding valerian children
further increased his power however the
valyrians were generally seen as lesser
than the targaryens
the appearance of princess rhaenys
targaryen the queen who never was varies
even within martin's writing in fire and
blood she's described as a great beauty
who had black hair and pale purple eyes
since she wore the traits of both her
baratheon mother and the targaryen
father she had a thin body and face into
her old age but her raven locks became
shrieked with white in her later years
rainy was a wild child she wore her hair
down preferring it to hang loose and fly
in the wind as she rode her dragon
melees men would sooner put the round to
the torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
however in martin's 2013 novella the
princess and the queen which was later
expanded into fire and blood rhaenys is
described as having the typical silvery
gold hair of a targaryen in both
instances however rhaenys is younger
than she's portrayed in the series house
of the dragon she's 16 when she marries
corliss valarion who is then in his late
30s eve best and steve tustan play the
characters more like contemporaries on
the show and the actors themselves are
only six years apart in age so far best
hair has also been done up in some
gravity-defying feats of styling which
isn't consistent with how this
formidable princess would have fashioned
it herself
fans likely found it shocking when the
king began to court 12 year old lady
lena valarion a daughter of his cousin
and his master of ships martin explains
that she inherited the beauty of a true
targaryen from her mother as well as her
father's adventurous spirit
you could not ask for a stronger match
than lena he adds that she was more
interested in flying than in boys and
that she had a great mane of silver gold
ringlets that fell down past her waist
in short that crazy white curly wig is
book accurate as is her fascination with
dragons though her parents have coaster
and what to say to the king laina would
rather hear stories about valerian and
vegar from viserys who is no longer a
dragon rider and doesn't exactly share
her enthusiasm for the winged beasts
cordless and rhaenys have two children
one of whom is laynor valarian he comes
with his own dragon an undersized for
agile silvery grey creature named sea
smoke who we see blazing into the
battlefield in episode three lenore is
talked about in fire and blood as if he
is attractive martin says he has an
aqualine nose silver white hair and
purple eyes again no skin colour is
mentioned but he's not known for being
stereotypically masculine his sister
lena is described as being almost as
pretty as her brother while the features
of the other valarians aren't
necessarily important plot points leno's
physical attributes do become a pivotal
part of the story going forward at least
in the book
the early episodes of house of the
dragon makes it pretty darn clear
everyone especially princess rhaenyra
thinks sir christine cole is a dreamboat
just before he bests her uncle at her
brother's name day tournament he asks
foreigner for her favor when he takes
off his helmet the princess and lady
alison are taken aback by that olive
skin that's wavy brunette hair and those
puppy dog brown eyes what kristen lacks
a noble birth bannerman and presumably
money he makes up for in smolder and
real world combat experience it could be
the latter that sways rhaenyra to choose
him for the kingsguard well let's be
honest it's probably the former
i choose sir kristin cole
sir christian cole is a tall dark and
handsome object of everyone's affection
in fire and blood too martin rides her
teeth a comely young knight of three in
20 years with pale green eyes cold black
hair and easy charm he's a favorite of
all the ladies at court including
rhaenyra who begs for him to be
appointed to the post of her personal
protector perhaps my prince recalls when
i knocked him off his horse in both the
novels and the series he's extremely
handy with his morning star
one of the consistent complaints that's
been directed at house of the dragon is
the portrayal of the woman with whom
prince damon is smitten
massaria specifically that criticism has
to do with the accent that actress
sonoya mizuno has been asked to affect
the distractingly thick dialect is a
show invention
i came to you to be liberated in both
the text and the show bessaria is an
exotic dancer and sex worker from the
city of lis who becomes prince damon's
mistress and confidant in print she is
also known by the nicknames lady misery
and the white worm that's because her
hard life has hardened her outward
appearance which is described as milky
white though book massaria is written as
laith and lissam in her younger days
martin who seems preoccupied with the
waste measurements of his female
characters writes that she thickens an
older age it should be noted that in
fire and blood she is actually pregnant
when damon steals the dragon egg
intended for their baby's crib
[Music]